continues happening to us it's going
good maybe we open the door Julia
Roberts and keep us on them and Kevin
Bacon and it's just it's exciting to be
a part of the reboot and the script is
really good
a true 90s cult classic now reimagined
with the new cast sure to be a
heart-pounding [ __ ] with the goal of
leaving you flatlined you die in the
movie no I mean I'm not yeah but
everybody's going to our waters now no
they're okay yeah three minutes Jaime
only did two what can I say so
competitive I'm going that five minutes
seven minutes
no one's ever come back from that but
there will be a nod to the first
Flatliners Kiefer Sutherland is back I'm
going again no way Mouse I've been
bumped twice bidding starts at four
minutes four minutes yeah the brace you
went for 350 wait wait wait
it was a mistake we almost lost him but
so far it's top secret on what impact
he'll have on the newbies Flatliners was
an unbelievable experience you know at
that time I was madly in love with Julia
Roberts we had a fantastic cast charging
200 it's a good day to die right
you